longtime protector of Tom Brady in a
longtime New England Patriot a multiple
Superbowl champion and he is now on to
talk about his wonderful foundation the
light foundation and also announce his
return to the game to play with Gronk
and Brady in Tampa because that's what
everybody does met like how are you mad
good as I once was but I may be as good
once as I ever was really Wow Matt did
you get that in a fortune cookie man
that sounds like that from a guy named
Toby Keith oh jeez I could just think
it's now you don't win the country every
day when you wake up and you're starting
you know a beautiful morning a little
bit a little bit good old boy and you
know pickin and grinnin oh yes that's
exactly how I fare Matthew how have you
been man how's everything buddy I'm
doing great little strange little
strange here in New England you know in
this post Brady era and you know of
course the pandemic and everything else
has to hit at the same time we're pretty
sure he caused that yeah we left here
but yeah strange times but we're doing
well well I'm glad to hear that
so let's get into this real quick your
your foundation the light foundation
I'll give you the floor on what people
and how they can get involved before we
get strolling down memory lane together
here well listen I appreciate it this is
a big time and a lot of nonprofits are
struggling right now you know during
this pandemic but um you know we figured
with all the excitement and Brady
heading down to Tampa and taking Gronk
with him that people would want to go
down there and see a game in Tampa
featuring not just Brady but also drew
Brees who you know was my quarterback at
Purdue and an unbelievable guy so this
raffle that we have at game day Tampa
calm if people go to game day Tampa calm
and they love football and they want the
opportunity to meet drew Brees Tom Brady
and Rob Gronkowski game day Tampa calm
is how you do it you can buy your raffle
tickets as many as you want
for as little as 10 bucks you get 10
tries
all the proceeds are going to go to
light foundation and if you win you're
coming to Tampa all-expense-paid trip
Hotel airfare the whole nine Mike
Alstott good luck you're mine another
Purdue guy he'll be there hosting the
winners as well we get the field passes
and you know it's just one of those
things if you love football you know
this is the ultimate no question about
it man and that's why you know the NFL
didn't wait very long schedule release
put in Brady's first game as a Buccaneer
in breezes house in New Orleans and
obviously you know how special a
building that is for Tom and the
Patriots having been the spot where you
know the first went down for that Super
Bowl but that's let's go hit the Wayback
Machine let's start with Brees first so
you were were you in the same class
together in Purdue were the same year
with him yeah he came in the year after
me it actually got to Purdue and Joe
tiller thought it'd be a great idea to
you know put me at tight end I did play
a little bit of Titan in high school but
those days quickly left me after my
freshman my true freshman year Purdue I
had hurt my shoulder in a training camp
that followed that season and I swallow
the couch basically and took a year off
and so by the time I came back as a left
tackle you know at a very spell 270 drew
Brees
stepped in took over you know the
quarterback position and man we had we
had some incredible years so did you did
you know how special this guy could be
from from jump mat or was it something
where you watched him you know begin to
blossom what was it like back in that
day with him it it's interesting he he
gets there and it's a guy that people
talked about is all he would have been a
big recruit you know he's from this you
know incredible Texas town and you know
his grandfather is a coaching legend but
he's just not big enough and that was
the knock on drew his entire career even
coming into the NFL you know he's a
great quarterback but it's not big
enough but when he got there it was very
clear from
day one that you know this guy was
special I mean his ability to you know
his accuracy and to this day I mean you
know coach Belichick when we'd be in
meetings he tell the defensive backs
he's like look you can be all over his
receivers but Drew Brees is gonna put
the ball where only his guy can catch it
and he's going to do it that way every
time so you know he's been a special
player since since he started throwing
that rock around so and then you get
drafted by New England second round 2001
draft and man you're thrown straight
into it right I mean correct right into
the fire man he built ride me in camp on
the right side and put me a right tackle
and it was atrocious so he didn't have a
whole lot of options we had a lot of
injuries so he put me back on the left
and ended up starting the season at left
tackle and man it was a it was a heck of
a learning experience Oh 1 and all the
chaos we had oh my god I guess so um so
let's let's get to the the moment were
you in the huddle when Brady came
running in that day with Mo Lewis oh
yeah ok yeah I can still hear the hit
that mo Lewis put on Drew Bledsoe and it
was on our sideline we're at home and in
Gillette Stadium the old Foxboro Stadium
actually right back that up a little
where where we had rats run across our
feet in meetings almost daily rich I
don't know if you remember those days I
mean you spent a lot of time in
Foxborough over the years oh yeah oh
yeah old Foxboro Stadium was it was it
was worse than a lot of the high schools
in Ohio and so that's not saying a whole
lot
no oh my gosh
so Bledsoe goes out Matt light and then
you're in the huddle and Tom Brady
enters what was it like in that huddle
when Tom got in there and you knew that
Bledsoe was hurt to the point where you
heard the hit on the field yes it was I
think at the time it was just like okay
well the next man up you know it was
like okay we've
we're moving on and this is going to be
awkward I mean drew bledsoe the year
before it signed a 10-year you know 100
million dollar contract you know here's
the the number one player on our team by
far is out of the lineup now we didn't
understand that his hit was a severe as
what it ended up being but tommy steps
in and you know what he's calling the
plays
everything's fluid everything's you know
seemingly right as rain you know and and
and it's not like we we ended up winning
that game but he came in and performed
really well but not no one had the idea
in their mind that this was a guy nobody
did
good thing not at all huh I mean even
but the story goes man in training camp
you know Tom looked the roll looked the
part and everybody kind of figured that
he was ready to go by the time that he
he got the shot was that the Indian was
that a prevailing thought at the time
again I know you're just a rookie but
was that a thought at the time I don't
know I don't know that it was I mean
Michael Bishop you know was there and he
was really the guy that was looked to as
the number two guy during training camp
you know we lost dick Rabine who was our
quarterback coach at a time he died of a
heart attack in training camp that year
she and you know I think that yeah it
was a wild year I think that that
actually probably opened the door for
you know Tommy and and and and the
coaching staff to reevaluate and do
things but I'm not really that sure that
they felt like they had a clear winner
in Tommy until probably about the
Washington game that year two or three
games into it so what was it what is it
about that game man well I was being on
the road tough environment you know
they're the it tested us in a lot of
ways and again we didn't win that game
but we fought back you know we we had a
chance to win it right at the end and it
told us a lot about you know what we had
in Brady and what we had in our offense
and you know I think that that game was
a big turning point in that season for
us
time Super Bowl champ Matt light here on
the Rich Eisen show stroll down memory
lane as he announced today a raffle for
the light foundation to go hang in Tampa
with Tom Brady and Rob Gronkowski and
the day that you do it is when the
saints come in and the quarterback he
protected in college Drew Brees will be
available for you to meet and hang out
with it's again entered here at game day
Tampa calm to win that raffle Matt Light
here on the Rich Eisen show you know
Matt we were having to talk the other
day about which last dance like
documentary we'd love to see about a
long-standing period that we can you
know reminisce about run-up tell the
story to the last dance between and in a
in a in a dynastic run the Patriots the
one that won our that at least is be the
one that I would love to see do you
think that would ever happen on planet
earth Matt like now you you're asking me
do I do I think it's over no do you
think we could ever have a last dance
type documentary that the people who
were involved it would sit down and tell
all in the same way that we're seeing
Jordan and the Bills tell all for the
Patriots come on now I didn't think you
would ever aspect wait you know you'll
you'll never get anything that you don't
need to know and you don't need to know
anything coming out of that world yeah
it's pretty tight-lipped in there and
you know I think Bill's done you know a
really amazing job when I think about it
over the years with the different people
that he's had in the locker room and and
how well he's been able to keep things
quiet I mean he likes he likes to have
it that way and I think it serves the
team best but no I I don't think you'll
ever get that opportunity right well I
don't know Matt I mean let's just put it
this way you know if you asked Jordan
that question you know just as they were
breaking up in 98 or anybody involved
with the Bulls you'd say never not a
chance and 20 years later we're seeing
all this footage because Jordan finally
agreed to let this happen because I
guess there's some part of him
wanted to tell the story and we're
seeing you know Belichick did the NFL
100 all-time team show as an analyst
maybe and we're seeing Tom take to
Instagram right now to refute stories to
make sure that the record set straight
maybe people want the record you know
out there and set things straight one
day oh it's possible it's possible and
look I think that you know when you saw
Nick Saban and and coach Belichick
during that HBO special that's right um
I think that that kind of told you a
little bit more and you got to see a
little bit more of a glimpse behind the
curtain but you know maybe there will be
a day where coach Belichick wants to sit
down and he wants to talk about these
moments you know in a little bit more
detail because he is a historian I mean
when it comes to military maneuvers and
battles and and and things that go back
in the history of this country as it
relates to the military he's really into
that kind of stuff and it's no different
whether it's the military stuff that was
inspired by his father or just the the
rich history of the NFL and the
different coaches I mean he he uses
examples of his time coaching with the
Giants or what he heard from this coach
you know thirty years ago and that coach
you know 15 years ago so yeah you may
get an opportunity like that but I think
it's it's many many years down the road
because I think he's still going to be
coaching here for quite some time so
what was it like you know we're seeing
about Jordan style of motivating and
Jordan style of pushing anything similar
to Brady in that regard or anybody else
but leaves to mind Matt yeah well look I
mean if you if you look at Brees and
Brady I use those two all the time in
terms of you know people you know what
makes them great how are they able to do
what they do they've been doing it for
so long it's such a high level
you know what's unique about them and
both of them have one thing exactly in
common and that's their competitive
drives and it shows up in everything
they do if they're throwing a piece of
you know trash in the in a waste basket
they've got to come
Pete at it both of them then it's
uncanny how similar they are in that
regard and so everything about what they
do is competitive they want to do it
better the next time and they did it
this time even if they did it perfect
this time they really want to do it
better
and so when you mix that with a very
cerebral approach to how they plan each
and every one of their days their
nutrition I mean you've seen it with
Tommy you're drinking up water you never
get a sunburn you're right you always
wear Uggs and steps in Cologne meaning
he's got a system right and I love the
bust his chops but it works and he does
it really well every single day are you
saying he wears the same cologne is that
what you just said Matt is that what you
say well we had a lot of fun back in the
day when he was doing some ads for
Stetson you know come you know that one
of the most fashion-forward people I
know and he's he's he's out there
repping you know my great-grandfather's
Cologne you know so we actually one day
I doused our Center yes in an entire
bottle that he left us in our locker yes
and I put it on as a shoulder pad so he
obviously had no idea that I just
covered him and he didn't smell it until
we'd stopped walking and the wind caught
up with him at which point he was
teary-eyed for most of the practices it
was extremely pungent and Tommy could
barely get in her center it was so bad
did he know it was you who sent you used
his personal scent on on the center did
he did he trace that to you Matt you
know I think you probably had a pretty
good idea
I was definitely blamed for many of
these shenanigans over the years so let
me get to the $64,000 question since you
obviously stay in touch with Tom and and
and and he's going to be doing his usual
graciousness and trying to help his
friends raise money for charity why did
he leave I get that question all the
time we're gonna be we're gonna be until
we get that last dance treatment may be
a decade plus from now we won't know but
why why did he why is he not finishing
any in a patriot uniform
Matt like well listen it's um it to me
it's it's really it's simple to
understand because you know I I put an
11 of what he ended up surviving 20
years on right
bill bill system is tough there's no
doubt about it when players come from a
different market and they get to New
England what they typically say at some
point is man this is a lot different
than where I came from and they really
push it and build demands a lot out of
you it's not an easy place to play
that's all understood I never had a
problem with it Tommy's never had a
problem with it but after 20 years you
know you start looking for ways you know
to enjoy the game a little bit more and
I think it truly is a function for him
that hey I've done it the hard way a lot
I put up with a lot I've been asked to
do a lot I'm ready to try it my way and
tried a different way and I want that I
you know he like I told you he loves
competition he wants that challenge I
mean this challenge is gonna bring out
the best in Tom Brady I don't know if
it's gonna go the way he ultimately
wants it to but I know one thing he's
gonna do everything in his power to make
that team a great team and you know I
think he's gonna have a lot of fun
playing in the NFL this fee so when you
say it's just you know after 20 years in
that and that is it I keep kind of going
back and forth on this Matt by the way
Matt like three-time Super Bowl champion
with the Patriots here on the Rich Eisen
show I go back and forth about it
because you know it's a damn shame that
he couldn't finish in the spot where he
where he started and then you sit there
and you hear about how the Eagles you
know the Eagles have their fun with the
Patriots a in the Superbowl year leading
up to that's Super Bowl that the that
they beat New England then saying that
we have more fun than New England and
then you know I think Bella cheque used
that against the Eagles when they beat
the Eagles in the regular season
subsequently saying we had fun doing it
you know I go back and forth between
like it's too damn bad that they
couldn't figure out a way to have more
fun but it did last 20 years and in the
same way I keep going back to this
a stance on it's just so amazing how how
you can fit it into the daily world
that's just the way that Belichick does
his business and you can't argue with it
you can't argue with it period it works
it's it's gotten results you know yes
and that literally is at the very core
of what happened here right so you can't
mess with it because it is successful
because it does work but it's not for
everyone and I would say this that Tommy
is much more in tune and so was I by the
way I wanted to know that if I'm gonna
lay it on the line and I'm gonna be out
there beat myself up week in and week
out I want to know that it means
something you know there's a lot of
teams and there's a lot of players that
I've talked to over the years but they
knew they didn't have a chance going
into a lot of their games they knew they
weren't prepared well they knew that
they didn't you know necessarily you
know have the components that they
should have went out there and got they
knew they had guys that weren't
performing well but they were you know
pulling the wool over the coach's eyes
they knew they weren't gonna win I
wouldn't I would hate to show up every
day and have that betta mentality but
you look at a Chris long when Chris long
was here for a season mmm did he have
success yes did he did he enjoy it
absolutely not
he was in the category of hey you know
what when is great but I don't want to
go through that to win so it's not for
everybody but again I think the points
really important when you do it the way
bill asked you to do it there's a lot of
success that has had and there's no
doubt about that but for Tommy you know
20 years of doing it at a very high
level 20 years of you know basically 50%
of the time that he you know he he took
on a season he was going to a Super Bowl
and he won a good number of him so you
know time for a change for him and I
think we're gonna have a lot of fun I
think it's the best year in the history
of the league to study what great
players and coaches do when they're
tested yeah that's no doubt about it and
in in that regard and then one couple
more minutes with this and then we'll
I'll let you go on with your day and
we'll remind everybody again how they
can help your foundation Matt
is that in terms of going in a different
direction after a 20-year long
relationship Bruce Arians I mean my gosh
just a you know obviously somebody who
is demanding but is a lot more you know
he's a different personality let's put
it that way and and Gronk will be there
and the good times can roll again and
then you know Belichick when I asked him
during the scheduled release show when
he was kind enough to you know chime in
from from his Nantucket kitchen I asked
him about you know what it's like to not
have Brady and he's like you know what
we we did it once with Matt Cassel we've
done it before with Hoyer you know
obviously they're different quarterbacks
but they have prepared for without Brady
before and we'll just do it again and
and it sure looks like it's stead him
now that's gonna be having his time in
that spot yeah and I think they like him
I think that you know there's there's
enough familiarity there's enough of
knowns of course there's a lot of
unknowns because you don't know anything
fully until the bullets are flying for
real and and there's been time for the
opponents to kind of figure out you know
what what that kid can do and what he
can't do and then and that there'll be
of course changing their game planning
and tactics and all that stuff but for
now I think that they feel really good
about you know what they have but what
they don't have is the ability to do the
things at this time of year that they
normally would be doing in the mini
camps and just being around each other
in the locker rooms and training and
working out so you know really an
interesting time to see what they do
when the lights get turned back on and
these teams start going back to work and
and the type of things that they're
gonna be asking these guys to do will be
really interesting especially for a guy
like steno because he he needs the time
you surprised Gronk up I came back man
no not at all you know it was
interesting when he retired I thought
you know what a good for you you had an
awesome run but watching him over the
last year and he lives just down the
road from me here in Foxborough the guys
in better shape than I've seen he's
always been in great shape but I mean he
has taken working
out to another level and he's got more
energy than any person on earth he's
he's the he's the the Great Dane its
tail's always wagging he's probably
licking his nuts when you're not looking
but you know he's just always
happy-go-lucky and and he's been working
it so and I knew that if Tommy was gonna
go somewhere else he because he was
looking for you know a little bit more
fun - in a different atmosphere that he
would come back and I'm glad they were
able to get it done because again who
doesn't want to see Rob Gronkowski out
there making big plays streaking down
the field and I think they're gonna ask
him to do that I think you're gonna ask
him to just you know don't do as much in
the run game maybe let's save your BOTS
let's save this guy's you know body but
let's let him stretch the field and
let's let him be that great target that
12 loves to hit well when you say who
doesn't want to see it Matt you're
talking about every Patriot fan I mean
if Brady in a different uniform if Brady
in pewter if Brady if they actually dare
to go in a throwback uniform and put
Brady in a popsicle uniform for just a
week I mean just that visual alone will
be difficult for Patriots fans to unsee
as if that's not gonna be difficult
enough the fact that Gronk says you know
what I'll come back and play as opposed
to last year when they really could have
used him they really could have
potentially had a much better final year
for Brady Brady might not even be gone
if Gronk decided to play last year and I
understand that there's a lot of
circumstances there I think every
patriot fan will have a very difficult
time seeing Gronk streaking down the
field and Mike Patriot ran across the
way and Chris Brock when you're not in
your head correct very much so I think
everything myself a headache pretty much
in my head Matt well III honestly the
vibe we get out here is that people
understand it they you know they they
love both those guys but especially
Gronk you know gerak was huge in the
community huge with places like Boston
Children's Hospital and all that so I
think when you have somebody that you
know approached you know his profession
and then his personal life the way he
did he's gonna get a lot of love even
though he's not in a Patriots uniform
he's gonna get a lot of love you know
and I know one thing I'm tired
seen him on WWE that stuff's got to stop
I think it will right I think it's got
that's got to man it's got to that's got
to be in a contract somewhere I know you
can't you can't do any downhill skiing
and all the stuff that I use dude you're
any offseasons all right you're not
supposed to WWE should definitely be
high on that list man Matt you've been
sharing a lot in this conversation and I
greatly appreciate it one more time
where can people go and help raise as
much money for the like Foundation as
possible with this raffle man I
appreciate it brother always talk to you
a game-day Tampa calm gameday Tampa calm
all-expense-paid trip man we're gonna
have an awesome weekend that's November
8 and to your point you made earlier
they're gonna be playing in the season
opener and then by this November 8 game
if you win and we take it down there I
think it's going to be a heck of a game
and they'll probably a lot on the line
who knows how it's all going to shake
out but it'll be fun to watch Brees and
Brady go head to head on Tampa and then
meet-and-greet with those guys
afterwards so if you love football
here's an awesome opportunity you know
spent 10 bucks spend 50 bucks and you
get entered into a secondary prize which
is not a bad one either it's sweet
tickets for Gillette season opener so
awesome raffle all the proceeds will
benefit of Life Foundation our
Leadership Academy and the work we do
with kids in the outdoors fries Brady
Grunk Alstott and and you help out the
light foundation that's a win man game
day Tampa calm love you Matt lied it's
been too long it's been too long and you
know any time I can ever you you call
any time hey I got a raffle I got
something going on you always have the
floor here you were always great to me
when you were you know winning
championships and I was getting started
in NFL Network and then with my podcast
you've always been available so I'm
always available for you you know that
well I appreciate your brother you're
one of my favorites and I every time I
think about the combine I just see you
streaking down the field
the I mean people don't understand what
a great athlete you are and I hope that
we can bring that to life down the road
a little bit well Matt you know us
Michigan men at the combine
you know we're over let it open up
that's enough just believe it and we're
over looked
we're over looked at the combine but we
have a heart that beats inside that you
can't teach you just either wake up
whether you don't but you knew that
already with us machine right you're
just like an ultimate seventh rounder
you know just makes them six hundred
ninety-ninth overall I'm gonna keep
comparing myself to the other Michigan
men late 6th all eight six
I'm a late sixth okay take care of right
back at you thanks man appreciate it
that's Matt light